to anyone working in the film industry
sujata if they had to put a time limit
on becoming a working professional
what would that be
never put a time limit on Art I would
say
because I I have found throughout my
years there have been a lot of my
friends and acquaintances that I've been
in touch with or met in acting class or
through writing and Anyone who puts a
time limit on it such as
if I don't do this thing within a year
or if I don't do this particular goal
within two or three years then I'm going
to go back to XYZ which could be
anything which could be in my case you
know I have an engineering degree so if
I were to say that okay I need to get to
direct a studio film within five years
or else I'm gonna go back to engineering
I feel like the universe hears that and
listens to that and says okay you have
this backup plan so
it it would it won't give you that first
thing that you want and I I just think
it's a everybody says this but it's a
marathon not a Sprint and I've noticed
that you know there are goals that I
hope to have wished to achieve by this
point which I haven't achieved but I'm
enjoying the journey and the journey has
been so much fun so it's all about
waking up in the morning
being excited that you actually get to
pursue your dream
and enjoying the moment that you're in
whether it's oh you get to go pitch to a
certain executive or Studio or network
today or whether it's you get to go have
coffee with a certain writer that you uh
are inspired by and and just taking
those little experiences and making that
exciting and making that a goal as
opposed to I need to sell a show by this
date or I need to be a series regular by
this date
um so I truly believe you can't put
a time limit on your dreams
when you were getting that engineering
degree was that your plan a at the time
no
that was always my plan B so
I I'll take it back to my childhood
where I was always dancing singing
writing acting but I was also really
good at math and science it came easy to
me and when I entered Middle School I
started doing plays when I entered High
School I started doing musicals and I
was always dancing every week and my
parents were very supportive and they
would come to Guys and Dolls every night
and bring a bouquet of flowers and cheer
for me and it was always really exciting
but then I was also taking AP Physics AP
Bio AP chem AP Calculus and killing it
on those exams as well so my plan my
master plan I started
thinking about when I was about 16 or 17
and I said to myself okay I can't move
to Hollywood at the age of 17. so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go get this
engineering degree and
take it from there and then move out to
LA after I graduate and so I went to get
my engineering degree and in the
meantime continued to do plays and
musicals and continue to write in
college I took a semester of
screenwriting I took a semester of
playwriting and then I the summer before
my senior year of college I interned at
a company called Accenture which is a
global consulting firm really big name
um they're on par with Deloitte
intuition Ernst young and
had a fun summer interning there and at
the end of that summer I was offered a
full-time job so this was even before
going into my senior year so they asked
me
where I wanted to work what city I
wanted to work in and I said Los Angeles
and I said Los Angeles and they said
great that's where we'll send you after
you graduate so I went into my senior
year already having a job
and as soon as I graduated I moved to LA
on accenture's dime and then I was on a
salary
so I was making a shitload of money at
the age of 20 pretty much and
the thing about Consulting is you never
have to
work unless you're placed on a project
so basically that entire year that I
worked there I was only on a project for
about two weeks and I was the worst
Accenture employee you could ever think
of and I just had all my phone calls go
to my cell phone never went into work
and in the meantime what I was doing was
meeting with agents I was going to
acting class I was
getting head shots I was auditioning and
at the end of that year working for
Accenture I got laid off which was also
awesome
because I got Severance I got
unemployment and for about eight to ten
months I believe I was just yeah I was
just like making money and that's when I
ramped up my auditioning and about I
don't know months later I booked three
National commercials in a row so that's
when my professional career started I
believe and in the meantime I was still
writing scripts still writing shorts
writing short stories poems songs Etc
and
that's how I got into acting but it was
all part of the master plan of like okay
I don't want to
be a burden to my parents
I want to be able to support myself
what's the best way I can do that okay
let's take this job in this other field
which is kind of the perfect day job to
be honest and then I moved out here and
did it on my own
how did you get word that you were being
laid off
what was hilarious was I was like I told
you I was a terrible employee so it was
a round of layoffs a bunch of employees
were getting laid off at the same time
and I was one of them I came in and the
HR lady who I had become friends with
she was really sad and disappointed that
she had to lay me off and I was like I'm
good
please don't waste your emotions on me
and and it was it was a good day
foreign
how many plan B's have you had while
you've been here in Los Angeles I've had
zero plan B's I I've had the day jobs
which have been really fun actually I
think there was always a dream of me
even being an engineer the dream that
you see in TV and in the movies of an
aspiring actor is they're working at a
restaurant or they're working as a
Hostess somewhere and that's what I did
and I had so much fun because
I was finally surrounded by creative
people because everyone working in the
restaurant business in Los Angeles
generally tends to be an artist and that
is their day job so I had a blast I
worked at a diner I worked at a fancy
Steakhouse and then I realized that I
really loved hostessing so I was working
the front of desk at these places and it
was really fun I was meeting all these
people working at really hot
trendy spots in LA and making friends
and I never considered that a plan B
that was always just me making friends
and making my home in Los Angeles
surrounded by the people that I finally
wanted to be surrounded by
yeah those can be fun jobs I know they
can be stressful though too especially
if you think that
there is no time limit for them I think
they're romantic for a while but there's
also a trap of being in them too long I
think that can really weigh people down
how do you handle or how did you at that
time well-meaning comments maybe from
family and friends
um that were like that's great you know
we love that you're still pursuing like
you're dancing and and acting but you're
going to need something more stable or
you can't make real money from this
things like that
well coming from
immense a little bit more maybe than
usual and I just handled it by I'd be
like well this is the money that I made
on the commercial and so I'll just like
book another commercial and we'll see
what's what happens obviously it's not
that easy you don't just go out and book
another commercial but I was making
steady progress so so it did something
that my my dad would say was why don't
you go to get a master's in acting or
it's always about more education and and
I was like well you know I'm taking
Upright Citizens Brigade classes and I'm
taking really fun
um other drama type acting classes and
I'm taking sketch writing classes and
and everything I write like I get a
little bit better every script I write
is a little bit better than the one
before and
so I just really had to explain to my
parents like this is what I'm doing I'm
continuously studying I'm continuously
growing and I don't necessarily need to
go do a master's program somewhere
so you showed them like here's here's a
residual check or here's whatever the
buyout check that I got for this
commercial and and maybe that quelled
some of their anxiety yeah I think it
was more about okay
for your food are you eating healthy are
you out on the street somewhere and and
so it was mostly about
just having a stable life as opposed to
um I think their version of the
Hollywood dream was more
the people living on the streets and and
doing Shady things to succeed and I was
like you know that's in your soap operas
that you watch
but that's not real life Hollywood
there's just a lot of people who are
working really hard to achieve their
dreams and continuously growing in terms
of their art and that's what I want to
do
what kind of heart do you think it takes
to pursue this business
a strong heart
I believe as an actor
you face so much rejection pretty much
on the daily and that has made me a
stronger filmmaker I believe as a
director you're continuously facing
rejection and I'm really thankful that
over these
past few years I've faced so much
rejection as an actor that the rejection
as a filmmaker doesn't affect me
emotionally I just say okay so you
didn't want it then I'm gonna move on to
the next person and they might say yes
and I'm going to move on to the if that
person says no I move on to the next
person they might say yes
because as an actor you are continuously
putting yourself on tape you're
continuously auditioning and you may
book I believe the statistic is one out
of every 70 roles that you audition for
and so I take that mindset into my
filmmaking and my writing and my
directing as well
and aside from the rejection what about
seeing friends and peers at different
levels around you I mean you've had
great success but I know maybe for
others or even myself or even in the
beginning maybe you see that oh wow this
person is doing really well and then you
have to kind of like
look at yourself and go oh wow what how
like how come I can't emulate that I
mean that's I think human nature yeah so
I think that is has personally happened
for me so when I started awkward black
girl that was about 10 years ago and I
was on this journey with Issa Ray and
the only thing I took from that Journey
was something positive which was to be
continuously inspired by her and to
follow the road that she has carved out
for us and I think it's really fun to
watch your friends succeed and I'm
really excited we have this really
burgeoning South Asian American
Community slash Asian American community
in Hollywood that we're finally starting
to come together and support each other
and support each other's projects and
you know definition please came out
virtually through the festivals and
after that even this year I know of
three other indian-american indie films
that are shooting and I'm so excited to
be able to support them and they have
all my friends in it and and I did a
cameo in one of them but it's exciting
to watch the growth and I believe 10
years ago there was more of a
competitive element to that like there
can be only one so there can be only one
South Asian American Film coming out and
there can be no others and that that
thinking has changed completely and I
believe
every you know a rising tide lifts all
its lifts all boats and it's really
exciting to watch my friends grow and
make their films and be able to put them
out because I believe
Hollywood has this way of making ethnic
stories slash diverse stories very
monolithic like one point of view this
is the only story that we're going to
tell about this group of people and now
we're seeing all these different kinds
of stories with within that group of
people so it's exciting to watch I think
we're living in a fun exciting time in
terms of filmmakers of color
so maybe it's less so about competition
anymore because so many people are
creating their own work whereas before
it was waiting to be picked yes yeah
before it was I'm just at home waiting
for my agent to call me and that's not a
good that's not a healthy place to be
you it puts you in a in a negative
mental state and it's exciting when uh
like I said I watched Issa create her
own work put Aqua blacker on her credit
cards and
um succeed and make season two and get
the kind of press that she got just on
her own and so I was like I can do that
if she did it I can also do it so so it
pushed me to okay I'm gonna create my
own content I'm going to put it on my
credit cards I'm gonna I'm gonna
generate my own press and so so it's
really exciting because I believe
nowadays we're all helping each other
and there's a lot of positive energy and
Vibes going around
what else does it take to keep at this
day after day year after year I love
what I do I'm so lucky to be doing what
I do I know that
I come from a world where my friends are
doctors Engineers they work on Wall
Street they are lawyers they are
business people and I am so thankful
that I have found a passion that I wake
up every morning I'm like
what can I do today what kind of idea am
I going to be inspired by
it's it's just really exciting to be an
artist and
that's what keeps me going just waking
up in the morning and realizing that I
get to live out my dream day after day
and they're gonna be
sad days when you like don't book a job
or what your script doesn't go a certain
way or where your film gets rejected by
a festival but the positive days
outweigh the negative and that's what
makes it exciting and also
in entertainment your life can also
change with one phone call and I think
the possibility of that keeps me going
as well
have you ever had long stretches of
silence and if so how do you keep
yourself motivated or what are you doing
in between
I don't really have stretches of Silence
I will say I think the pandemic made
everyone slow down and within that
pandemic what I did was I put myself
through my own kind of film school I
suppose so I started watching uh I was
taking movies off the AFI film list that
I've never seen before I had never
watched Goodfellas before I'd never
watched Midnight Cowboy I'd never
watched The Graduate all these films
that people talk about and I was so
blown away by all of them I started
watching more International Cinema
Akira Kurosawa and another thing that I
did was I watched a bunch of television
shows that people always talk about I
watched The Sopranos I watched the wire
I watched all of Twin Peaks I just
finished watching all of Larry Sanders
and that stuff
inspires me and it's exciting to watch
these amazing actors these Amazing
Stories this amazing dialogue and even
with like Twin Peaks like the crazy
weird absurdness of it all and and I I
guess I did take that time to just learn
and be inspired by others who have come
before me and that was exciting so that
that's probably the only quiet time that
I've had but it's still very much
soaking in knowledge and it's not time
where I turn off my brain I'm I'm still
learning from my quiet time
so during this quote unquote quiet time
did you create anything I did I was very
productive
and I wrote two features I wrote three
pilots and a couple of different pitches
had a couple different ideas but I'm
very excited about the projects that I
wrote and we've been taking them out
we've been pitching them and you know if
if no one picks it up maybe I'll just go
do go shoot it independently again and
so it's really exciting because I feel
like I really found myself during the
pandemic and found my voice and was able
to sit down at the computer and
the the words were just coming through
me and onto the page and it was it was
fun it was fun and and I did focus on
comedies during the pandemic and I think
that was part of it where you know the
world is going through this dramatic
upheaval and I didn't want to pull that
into my daily life so I was making
myself laugh every day
can you talk about living below your
means and how you've adopted that early
in your career so you don't want to
maybe spend too much here or there get
too confident like this amount's always
going to be coming in
have never really in my life
needed like expensive stuff
and I've always been able to live below
my means I'm really good at balancing my
budget and my checkbook and even when I
I mean when I was working at Accenture I
was making a ton of money and so I did
not spend that money so I did not live
how my co-workers lived and my
co-workers were buying
BMWs and living in these like really
fancy apartments in Manhattan Beach and
not but I I was always aware of my plan
and I was like oh I gotta save this
money because who knows like when I do
get laid off or when I do
um when Accenture Finds Me Out
and realizes that I'm a terrible
employee then I'm gonna need this money
to live on so just from there starting
there I knew that I needed to save and I
knew that I needed to live below my
means because after that I was you know
doing short films for uh USC and UCLA
that you don't get paid for and
I was doing a lot of free acting work
just to get the tape and and I was I was
living off you know my Accenture money
for a while and then and then I would do
the waitressing jobs and the restaurant
jobs and and that would pay the bills
and like I said I would book a co-star
here and there or a commercial and and
that would be a nice chunk of money
which I knew again that I couldn't spend
right away
um and so I I've always been pretty good
about living below my means something
that one of my friends Yvette Nicole
Brown told me that I always have on the
back of my head is if you're
a guest star you should be living like a
co-star if you're recurring you should
be living like a guest star if you're a
series regular you should be living like
a recurring and so I keep I keep that in
the back of my mind and I think about
that a lot and I tell her all the time
I'm like I'm always thinking about that
and she she's she gives good advice
so when you got let's say the first big
acting related check
did you have a temptation to I want to
splurge this on a b and c
and and did you reward yourself or did
you say no this is my this is my winter
money I need this
I said this is my winter money I need
this I don't think I've I've never
splurged on anything unless I needed it
so my splurges have always been
if I have a 10 year old laptop then I
need to get a laptop because it keeps
shutting down
or if I have a six-year-old phone then
I'm gonna get the new iPhone
um but I'm not someone who you know the
iPhone 13 just came out I don't need to
go rush out and get that
um I think
I'm very happy with small rewards when I
when I book let's say you know like
booking a commercial I'm like okay I'm
gonna go get pizza for my favorite place
or I'm gonna go get ice cream like like
food is something that I care about a
lot and the foods that I like aren't
very expensive so so that's a Splurge
for me I I'm not someone I will only go
out and buy a car if my car is on its
last legs and undrivable so I guess I'm
like really good with money in that
sense and I had a there's I love to
travel
um but
I have traveled a lot throughout my
childhood and even up through college so
even when I moved to LA I was like oh I
don't need to go to Europe because I've
already been to Europe or I don't need
to go spend my money in Asia because
I've been to Asia so so I I would always
keep that in mind and I'd be like well I
I actually need to get new headshots as
opposed to
um do something splurgy and crazy
so so that something that you can
reinvest back into whether it's your
acting career or a film is something
you'll put money into but it sounds like
always always
will be I'll be putting money back into
my career right but not you don't need a
new model of whatever car no no and I
love I love Groupon I love living social
I'm always looking for a deal
where are some of the best places that
an actor or creative can invest in
themselves what can they do I believe
the best thing that you can invest in is
your work so for example I did a short
film
in 2016 called cowboy and Indian and
this is how it came about basically I
was doing my taxes and I noticed that
there were these stocks that I had never
noticed before and I called
the number
that was that was on the tax information
sheet and I asked oh what are these
stocks and they said oh these were
gifted to you when you left Accenture
and I said excuse me okay how much are
they worth and they said fifty five
hundred dollars and I said send me the
check and they say well we don't
recommend you cashing out and I was like
send me the check and I got a check for
fifty five hundred dollars
that I put directly into funding my
short film cowboy and Indian which I
wrote produced directed and star in and
it was a really freeing experience
because I gave myself the permission to
fail on making that short because I knew
it was my first short film
it would probably turn out to be a piece
of but guess what nobody was going
to be blamed except for me because I was
putting my own money into it that I
didn't even know I had so it wasn't
money that I needed to make back I was
just like this was free money out there
that was mine and I had just discovered
it
so I had already written the short film
and it was a five page script and I put
my crew together put my cast together
and we went out to the desert to Joshua
Tree to shoot it it was a one day one
night shoot and came back went into
post-production and
when I when it was finished I said oh
this isn't bad I was like this is not a
bad first short film and I started
submitting it to film festivals and got
didn't get into any of the biggies you
know didn't get into Sundance Tiff
Tribeca or South by but I got into a lot
of Asian American film festivals and
Indian American film festivals and so I
did the festival circuit I traveled with
it uh I believe it got into over 15 film
festivals in 2017 2018 and it was just
really fun and it was amazing watching
it on the big screen along with four or
five other short films that were in the
same block as mine and I have never
regretted putting that stock money
into my short film
was that part of like a 401k that they
it wasn't part of a 401k it was just it
was just stocks it was it was stuff that
you could actually cash out and get the
the price of whatever it was at that
time
how did you meet Issa Ray
so I'm at Issa Ray on Twitter
this was like 10
plus a couple months year ago
10 years plus a couple months ago and
I had just left Facebook because I just
thought Facebook was so dramatic and
there was just too much going on with
having your elementary school friends on
there with your middle school friends
with your high school friends with your
college friends with your family I was
like I need to like not be part of this
chatter so I left Facebook before it was
even cool to leave Facebook and as I
left it I said to myself I was panicking
a little bit and I said well I need some
kind of social media What's it gonna be
and then I saw that Twitter was
happening and not happening like today
but it was it was a newish platform so I
was like okay I'm gonna make a Twitter
and then I got on Twitter and I started
following this this person Joshua at
film TV diversity and he would tweet out
different writers and producers and
directors and creators to follow so I
would just click follow on every single
one of them because I didn't know what I
was doing on Twitter and and there was
always really great advice coming from
Twitter from the people I follow in
terms of filmmaking and then she had
tweeted out follow Issa Ray she makes
web series and I said great followed her
she followed me right back and then a
couple days later she tweeted out I'm
looking for a mixed looking girl to play
my best friend in my next web series and
I dm'd her and I said hey I'm not mixed
but uh this is what I look like here's a
picture of me can I audition anyway and
she said yeah of course come on down and
she gave me the address and I pull up to
the how this is a house in a nice
neighborhood but regardless a house and
for any actors watching out there I
don't recommend you go to a house for an
audition that's super Shady you want to
drive away I did not drive away
I I was about to drive away but then I
saw Issa come out and she was talking on
her cell phone and I was like oh it's
fine it's a girl it's a woman still not
the right attitude to have
so I went into the house did the
audition it was super chill I was there
for about five minutes and then I left
and then a couple hours later she said
you booked the roll and I said okay cool
and then a couple weeks later
I went to issa's Dad's doctor's office
in Inglewood which where we would be
shooting awkward black girl and we just
shot a very quick 20-minute hallway
scene that I believe is in episode three
of awkward black girl where my character
is introduced and it was just me Issa
and her brother and her brother was
running the camera and the sound was
definitely attached to the microphone
was attached to the camera so there was
no separate sound system we had to come
hair and makeup ready and uh like I said
it took 20 minutes and then she Isa said
thank you so much and then I left and
I asked myself what did I get myself
into what is this web series like nobody
to do a web series was at the time and
that's how I met Issa Rae
that's a great story you'd been acting
what eight years prior to doing awkward
black girl well I've I would say I've
been acting
since I was like five or six just from
back home just putting on my own shows
putting on my own performances and then
doing plays in elementary middle school
and then doing
musicals and being in the chorus in
middle school and high school and so
I've been acting I would say pretty much
my whole life
yeah you did the web series for free
correct yes I did and that's an
interesting decision I think at the time
I was doing a lot of stuff for free so
like I said I was auditioning for AFI
films I was auditioning for USC films
and UCLA films and most of the time
those films didn't even get finished and
and that was the tragedy of it all
because I didn't mind doing
working for free because it was always
really fun
but I believe that a lot of the time the
filmmakers came up against
wanting their project to be perfect
and then going through the
post-production per process and
realizing that it wasn't what they had
envisioned and then
completely throwing it out and I believe
that is the wrong attitude to have as a
filmmaker as a Creator I truly believe
that you should
finish stuff and also put it out there
and also submit it to festivals and even
if it's not what you thought it was
going to be it could still be accepted
as something else and so that's the
exciting part of it even if you have
something that may not have the best
production quality or the best acting or
the best sound just put it out there and
guess what you're gonna learn from that
mistake and you're not going to make
that mistake again in your next thing or
project will be 10 times better oh and
then you just keep working you just got
to keep making stuff and putting it out
and then make the next thing so
something that I like to point out is if
you watch the first two or so episodes
of Awkward Black Girl on YouTube
the production quality isn't great the
sound isn't great
but there's something there there's
something there that makes you keep
coming back and then you notice as those
season one episodes go on oh I think
they got lighting I think they might
have gotten microphone they might have
gone a sound person
oh they're they're a wardrobe looks a
little bit better so I love
awkward black girl and that it it is on
YouTube and you can watch the
progression of how it just keeps getting
better and better and and I think that
was you know when I was doing free
projects
um I was just excited to be meeting
people and working with new people and
once again just be surrounded by
creativity
what do you think made that show so
popular what made an awkward black girl
Popular was that it reached an audience
that was being ignored by Hollywood
and it was black women
that were not used to seeing themselves
on screen and that's that's what was
really exciting about being a part of
that journey and watching as the
episodes came out one by one watching
the The View count keep growing and it
turned into a snowball and and we were
getting comments we were getting DMS we
were getting messages from people oh my
god I've never seen myself on screen
before this is me are do you have a
camera in my home are you watching my
life are you watching my relationships
are you watching my friendships and that
was the most exciting part of it because
like I said Hollywood has a way of
taking a group of people and making the
same story about them over and over and
over again and
and this was such a specific story from
a specific point of view that had never
been told before that had never been on
screen and
that was that was part of
why it became the success that it became
um season one episode seven
after we ended That season we did a
Kickstarter and we were looking for
thirty thousand dollars to make the last
I believe
four or five episodes and
we didn't know how much money we were
gonna raise and you know even the not I
remember we were having we were all kind
of hanging out talking about oh how much
should we ask for should we ask for ten
thousand should we asked for 12 15 and
they decided on 30 and we ended up
making fifty four thousand dollars and
once again that was proof that there
were people out there that needed to see
this that wanted to see this and wanted
to see how the season was going to end
what was going to happen with white J
and J and what was going to happen with
Jay at work and with her friends and so
that's what was really fun and exciting
to see that oh there is the possibility
of creating something that appeals to a
certain group of people that have never
seen themselves on screen before so
that's what
makes me so excited about creating my
work
sure and you think too because the
characters were it just wasn't about
stereotype it was about these are real
people not okay this person fits this
stereotype or demographic for this one
role we need this like
character relief kind of thing yeah I
think it was successful because each
character was a well-rounded individual
and a lot of the time
the the audience when they would message
us they would like oh my best friend is
exactly like that or the guy that I'm
dating is exactly like that so so we
were tapping into something real and and
non-stereotypical for sure
what did Issa Ray teach you about the
business once you learn just by watching
her
ASA Ray just taught me to
be true to my point of view and
get it out there no matter what no
matter how many rejections you get no
matter how many no's you get
every person has a unique story to tell
and
each story is important and generally
not out there yet and there are
audiences today that are not being
served by what Hollywood is offering so
I'm just excited to fill that void of
content
how did you end up on Felicia Day as the
guild after that oh I don't get asked
about the guild too much so this is
exciting Okay so
I believe it was season two of awkward
black girl The Guild was also
I believe one of the only other web
series that had been happening at the
same time so we were aware of the guild
um The Awkward Black Girl Scott Squad
was aware of the guild and and I I
believe it was just an audition so I had
gotten an email through my reps oh
Felicia day's web series they're casting
for certain roles in their Sixth and
last season and would you be down to
audition
and I had known of Felicia Day I had not
been watching The Guild but but I kind
of cross-coursed it
when I went in for the audition and and
it was really cool because as soon as I
walked in it felt like oh we're we're
like the two web series that are
happening right now this is really
exciting and they're both created by
women which was also an exciting thing
and so I went in and I auditioned it was
really fun and I also booked that job
and that was awesome to do I believe it
was happening at the same time when we
were shooting Awkward Black Girl season
two so I was working on both of them at
the same time and just had a blast and
Felicia is great and it was it was it
was really awesome to watch because they
they were in their sixth season so to
watch to go from one web series to
another that was so much ahead like like
the there were extras and there were big
sets and and it was it was fun it was
fun to be a part of that and to see
where a web series could go
if it went on for a couple more seasons
I'm curious why you didn't do definition
please as a web series did you feel like
it was better served as a feature or or
would you want to continue it on through
many seasons
because you could go many places with
things yeah yeah definition please to me
was always a feature and I'm not quite
sure why I decided on that I have
projects that are specifically TV
projects that are specifically film and
and for definition please I I didn't
even really
think of the idea until about 2015 when
I was in my UCB sketch writing class and
I wrote a four-page sketch about
spelling bee winners which served as the
basic premise for definition please and
then I had started going to Sundance in
2017 and that really inspired me to
create a film to be honest and and this
was also post cowboy and Indian where I
had made a short film and once again it
was really fun taking it around to film
festivals so for me definition please
was never a web series and it was always
a feature film you think it could be at
some point
I think my journey with definition
pleases over okay all right I want to
see like a high school reunions
different things you know right right
different dramas yeah yeah I think I
think there is a world that I created
that could it could keep going and
people want to know what happens after
Monica moves to Cleveland but I I truly
believe that once I'm done with the
story I'm pretty much finished with the
story and and and I have 10 or so other
projects that I'd love to get off the
ground and shoot so I'm excited to move
on to the next thing were you protective
of Monica as a character you know how
they they write like you know have
horrible things happen to your character
I realize you know you weren't making
that exact kind of film even though
there were family dramas but was it hard
to let Monica go
no no
I I have a way of detaching from my
stories and characters and so I want
them to
be real and be grounded and pursue the
path that their character would take and
and I don't take it personally as a
writer or a filmmaker and so I'm always
excited I think with Monica I love that
she is unlikable in the beginning of the
film and and you are kind of trying to
figure out why she's so mean to her
brother who seems really nice and and
and I love writing flawed characters as
well so so it was it was just fun to
write a character that had all these
different things going on and wasn't
fully good or fully bad
what would you say those two web series
did for your career The Guild and the
awkward black girl they just put me on
the map I believe in terms of exposure
even at that time I had just done
season two of awkward black girl I had
just done season six of the guild and
then I got a call from my commercial
agent at this point I did not have a
theatrical agent
and they said hey the casting director
arrested development is coming back and
the casting director wants to offer you
a small role and I said what how did
they even know about me I'm not
auditioning for TV shows or films right
now and they said they had been watching
web series and they just discovered me
so that was getting to do
an episode of Arrested Development was
really really special and and being on a
proper television set with hair and
makeup and craft services and them
picking up my outfit and being on set
with David Cross and Alia shocket that
was just
an experience that I will never forget
because I wasn't expecting it at the
time
would you say you're here now because of
those two series like has your life sort
of your career the trajectory of it
because of those series the timing was
right that it just brought other great
things into your life other roles oh
yeah I credit
awkward black girl with pretty much my
entire career and and the path that I
personally chose to take which is
creating my own content and putting my
own stuff out there and taking risks and
not sitting by the phone waiting for it
to ring waiting for my agent to call me
um almost with those calls when they do
come are like presents because I'm
continuing to make my own content and
then when my agent does call with
something I'm like oh that's cool that's
surprising and exciting so so I love
that about my life and definitely I
credit everything too
Awkward Black Girl
he talked about risk earlier waiting by
the phone and now you know that you can
take chances in a risk to create your
own work but even from a young age it
sounds like with the spelling bees
for however long that lasted that's a
risk that was definitely a risk
especially at that time I was a shy
introverted kid so to get up in front of
an audience I remember that moment
because when when you're in a class of
eight and you're just doing the spelling
bee there's no audience it's just like
you get your word right or wrong and if
you get it wrong you just sit and you
become the audience and I was around my
friends so I do remember going to the
Regionals
and seeing that huge audience and that
probably scared me off as well so you
know what I'm just making excuses for
spelling the word radish
but anyway so it I because I see you as
that you have a lot of you wouldn't be
fearful of of challenges but it seems
like you yeah I'm not fearful of
challenges now I will say like I said I
was a shy introverted kid and then in
seventh grade when I switched to public
school and had all these friends I
looked in the mirror and I said to
myself I cannot be shy and introverted
anymore and then I just switched and
then I was getting kicked out of math
class because I was talking too much
there was a discussion on Twitter a few
weeks back about the film Community the
writing community and the wrong way and
the right way to do something
and I just wondered what your thoughts
are on that like
is there a wrong way to make a movie is
there a right way you know you talked
about over the course of the pandemic
you made watching movies sort of your
film school but there is a dogma of you
know this is the right way to do
something the right way to enter a scene
to end a scene do you feel that or
everyone should have their own unique
Style
I don't feel like there's a right or a
wrong way I think there are greats that
have come before us that we can learn a
lot from and they all have their own
Styles and if you're watching something
like David Lynch and Twin Peaks you
notice that he he tends to break the
rules and and go into melodrama which
was like the best part about Twin Peaks
I just I just loved it so much but then
you then you watch something like Good
Fellas and that feels like what
uh
a film buff would say is the right way
to make a movie but but I think I I just
love all kinds of movies and especially
if you watch International films if you
watch something that I'm really inspired
by is Sethi G3 who is a Bengali
filmmaker I'm also Bengali and he won an
honorary Oscar in the 80s or the 90s and
he what he did was he kind of broke off
well he didn't want to make Bollywood
type movies which is what Indian India
was known for at the time and he just
went into the villages and started
um focusing on women in The Villages and
and he would write these amazing stories
about
just regular women and what they were
going through and and it wasn't about
being rich and it wasn't about Musical
dance numbers and and it was just like a
quiet story and so what I believe is
there's not a right or wrong way to do
or create art and I think what's
exciting to me is
when you do get out of those boxes and
and we were talking about risk when you
take a risk and and maybe it doesn't pan
out the way that you wanted to in this
project then you don't do it again in
the next one you take a different kind
of risk and I love when
projects surprise me I love it when they
go a certain way or do a certain thing
that I'm not expecting and that's what's
exciting to me about art which movies
and TV shows fall into as well has
anyone said that to you like this should
be more this if you if you do it more
this way it'll have more marketability
I believe that happens more in the
screenwriting process and not really in
the filmmaking process
I I get notes from my scripts and my
pitches and honestly most of the time
the notes are make the project better so
it allows me to think about the project
in a different way that I may not have
seen before and and that's what's really
exciting sometimes what happens is
you'll go through like a circle of notes
taking you back to that same place where
you started but now you're more clear
about why you started with that story so
it's I appreciate notes I love getting
very hard critical notes on my work and
and I won't necessarily take 100 of the
notes but each note allows me to think
about the scene or my characters or the
work in a different way so I'm like okay
where is this now coming from what is
the person not uh attaching onto what
what are they not getting in this part
and that's where the actual note is
coming from so getting notes to me is
very very awesome because generally
every time I've gotten notes and I've
done the rewrite it's a better script
than what I had written before
did anybody give you notes with
definition please like can you make it
go more in this direction and then we'll
have more marketability for it because
it's really just a story about you know
coming being a young person whether you
want to leave the nests or stay in your
small town it doesn't have to be
Bollywood it was just an experience that
happened to be different cultures that
all came together and knew each other
from high school yeah I got the I got
one note that I got
I believe it was during the script
process was
someone needs to die like it needs to be
in this climax moment like one of the
family members needs to die and I was
like
I don't think so I don't think that
needs to happen I'm really just trying
to you know make it a slice of life and
um this could be any family it just
happens to be a South Asian American
family in the center of it all and
that's what was exciting to me just to
show
Indian Americans as normal people just
like everyone else I think mostly when I
when I soft pitched it around to
production companies that I already had
relationships with they all said that it
was too small of a film for them to take
on without really giving me any notes in
terms of like oh if you made it like
this maybe we could we could shoot it
but uh I understood that pass or that
you know that rejection per se because
because it is a small film
and it's about you know there's no
explosions and there's no you know big
special effects or anything so it's not
one of the five Studio films that that
you know a big Studio would make
um but I I wanted to make this for
myself just to
just to get a story out there that I had
never seen before on screen
do you see that ever though in the film
industry or right you know with with
film and TV writing screenwriting that
there's there's definite like this is
the wrong way this is the right way I
think there is definitely a formula to
telling big budget films so if you're
writing a big budget film for a studio
then there is absolutely a correct way
to do that and uh I don't know if you
guys have read Thomas Lennon's book
called how to write movies and make
profit how to make movies how to make
movies for fun and for Fun and Profit
and fun is crossed out and one of the
first one of the first things that he
says in the book is if you're making a
movie for Sundance you need to put this
book down
and gives really explicit instructions
on how to write
and create a studio film and I just love
the book because I have applied it to my
indie films that aren't necessarily
Studio films but but it's also a really
easy read and it's funny and it's fun to
get through and it's awesome to hear his
experiences and stories as a studio
screenwriter as opposed to me who's
who's writing for indie films but
but yes I do believe that there is a
correct way to write a studio film with
certain beats and certain explosions in
certain moments that happen between the
stars of the film that you have to have
in there or also Stars won't to the film
how have you found your voice as an
artist
I've just
written stories that I want to write
I've never
tried to
write something that I don't want to
write and and I'll explain that in a way
that I've I've been pitched certain
books or IP and and at first it'll be
exciting but then I'm like I'm not I
don't care about this I don't care about
this subject I don't care about this uh
world so then I don't do it so I don't
do anything that I don't want to do and
most of the time I'm excited about my
original stories and and I'll get an
idea whether I'm inspired by a moment in
my life or
I'm inspired by a song or I'm inspired
by a hike that I went on those are the
things that excite me and and keep me
going from from the seat of the idea to
writing the outline to writing the
entire script if I'm not excited about
that seed of the idea then I can't keep
moving forward in order to finish that
script which is what I always want to do
like I said I always want to have a
finished product I have a ton of friends
who start scripts and then never finish
them or like I said they start short
films and never finish them but I think
the most important thing to do
especially with the first draft of
writing a script is just finishing it
the first draft is what I always call
vomit draft and it's never any good but
guess what it's 90 pages long great I've
reached my goal of 90 Pages now the hard
work is rewrite the first draft so then
I rewrite it and and I get it to a place
where I think it's
okay to be seen by the four or five
people that I trust to give me good
critical notes on my scripts and then
and then I get those notes and then I
continue to rewrite continue to rewrite
but for me it's always about getting
that page count to 90 Pages especially
with the first draft and then proceeding
with the rewrites from there
that's interesting you think the math
science part of your brain has really
trained you to make sure that you finish
things that that there's a that it all
works out yeah yeah I really do and it's
so strange because because that didn't
click until a few years ago where where
I'm really structured about writing
scripts and I'm like okay I'm gonna
write 10 pages this week and then 10
pages next week and I write it down on
my planner and I cross it off once I'm
done and I get to 20 40 60 80. and and
and that really excites me and so
um I I remember one thing from all of my
engineering years I walked into my first
class
in college and the teacher wrote out
engineer equals Problem Solver and I
said
huh I said I am a problem solver and and
I use that in all of my work I use that
in my screenwriting I'm like okay well
how do I get this character out of this
situation okay how do I how do I finish
the script how do I what's if I've
already written the end how do I get
there what are these middle scenes in
between
um even with uh being on set of
definition please I kept thinking about
engineering equals Problem Solver and I
was like okay we've lost this location
how am I gonna problem solve
getting a location without freaking out
my cast and crew in the meantime and so
I do believe uh
uh my training as an engineer and in
math and science has truly helped my
artwork because even in
um I mentioned that I also write poems
and I write songs and I had written
poems and then I got together with my
friend will Collier who composes our
music
and he taught me the basic structure of
a song and I could take that structure
and I'm like oh great I can definitely
follow this formula to write this song
So once again that was my math mind
writing and artistic song
I love that if you were to be the
teacher at a screenwriting course or
filmmaking and you wrote screenwriter
equals
we actually have a chalkboard here but
screenwriting equals and what would be
the other word on the end of the equal
sign
I'm gonna say Problem Solver okay
screenwriter equals problems okay
because you're always solving problems
you're you're coming up with the premise
and you're always putting your
characters into problematic situations
that they have to get out of and only
you can take them out of those
situations and and that's part of what's
exciting you let the characters guide
you into their own stories and and you
are now solving their problems
okay and then actor equals
Entertainer okay
and last but not least filmmaker equals
visionary
I like it how do you know what you're
creating is coming from your unique
voice
what I'm excited about it so
something that was really fun for me on
definition please is that when we
started shooting
I the day before we started day one of
shooting it felt like the way you feel
before the first day of school
and
I was really excited and I couldn't
really get to sleep but I knew that I
had to sleep
and that's when you know that's when you
know you're doing what you're supposed
to be doing and you're telling a story
that's unique to you and your point of
view when you're in that moment and
he just can't wait to wake up in the
morning and and get to work and
tell the story that you've been living
with for
a few years and that that's what's
exciting to me when I can
be excited about rewriting a script that
that I had uh poured my unique voice
into and and and you know be able to
change that or adjust it and make it a
better story and and I just get excited
like I said during the during the
pandemic when I was
um pushing out all these scripts it was
just a joy to sit at my laptop and get
back into these lives of the characters
that I had created and in each one of
those characters had their own unique
voice which wasn't necessarily mine so
it was exciting to take on those roles
as well
you say you don't take something on
unless it excites you so you already
know once you've taken something on you
know that you're committed to it you're
not going to you know because some
people might be persuaded oh yeah all
right I'll do it I'll do it but it
sounds like you already know you have a
real definition inside of you that you
know this is something I'm going to
stick with
I have no problem saying no to things so
I have walked away from a lot of big
projects and ideas that may have
made me a lot of money but that I wasn't
necessarily excited about so that that's
number one I listen to my voice I listen
to how I feel when I'm reading something
or being pitched something and so I I
suppose I have the Marie condo
philosophy of oh is this going to bring
me joy and generally if it's my original
idea yes and then I continue on with
that but if it's someone else's idea
then I really have to think about it and
say okay is this going to bring me joy
or am I going to get stressed out and
and I'm not someone who gets stressed
out ever so
so those are my two questions that I ask
myself in terms of taking on a role or
taking on someone else's work in terms
of writing or directing it
so have you ever rethought something
that you turned down and thought no oh
no you were very clear on it yeah very
clear very clear on it I I don't regret
anything in my life and you know a lot
of people would say oh well don't you
regret going to engineering school
instead of going to acting school or and
getting an Arts education and and like
you mentioned I use my engineering and
my math and science background to
uh create my scripts to create my
stories and they have gone hand in hand
which is really exciting so I've I've
never regretted anything any decisions
that I've made in the past
compels you to write
different things different ideas
I'm always inspired by
experiences so I think it's really
important for
writers to go out and experience life
and not just be sitting in their room
all day and writing so you know
something that I really loved from my
upright citizen Brigade improv and
sketch classes one of the assignments
that a teacher had given us was
go out and do
something new this week something that
you wouldn't necessarily do
try something new so
I think during that class I I ate
insects for the first time which I
didn't really love I I think I watched
like an old action movie I'm not really
into action movie so I just kind of
watched that and and it was great
because you have to expand your mind you
have to learn about different things and
and those things will inspire you so
whether it's a character who's really
into action movies whether it's it's a
scene at a restaurant where they're only
serving insects whether it's so I those
different experiences will inspire
something and strike a match in your
brain for maybe not a project that
you're currently working on but maybe
something in the future and so so I
continue to do that even after taking
the class I continue to
read something that I wouldn't normally
read or or try a new food that I that I
wouldn't normally try and that's that's
what's exciting to me just new
experiences I believe inspire me all the
time
how do you create a meaningful story
I think as long as you're telling the
story from your heart then other people
will gravitate towards it so
I wanted to tell a story about a
specific type of family that went
through Universal problems and
and I wasn't sure what an audience was
gonna think about it and and I really
made it for myself and I made it for my
friends and family because I knew that
they would enjoy it and then all of a
sudden different audiences were
pulled towards it and really enjoying
the film and that was that was kind of a
surprise to me
but but it's exciting to to find out
that your story that you put a lot of
heart into is also emotionally affecting
other people as well
did people come up to you after
screenings I mean we didn't have a lot
of screenings because of
coviduals so so it was more through
um tweeting at me or direct messaging me
or through emails where I was learning
that
these uh these people these audience
members who had watched the movie really
enjoyed it and really
felt connected to it and felt something
they felt seen you talked about making
sure you only do projects that you feel
compelled to do that you don't want to
do something you don't want to go to
something you don't want to be yet
what's your thought on creating a story
that's emotional versus one that's more
commercial
I like them both I'm trying to create
both stories I think it's possible to
create
a commercial story with emotion and
heart and I think that's that's the
beauty of
making a big budget film and you can
sneak heart in there
but but show it to a wider audience and
that's exciting to me I think I I love
comedy so I'm gonna stick to comedic
stories but even within that comedy I
believe there's gotta be heart no matter
what budget you're making the project
for and yeah I have ideas that are very
commercial and I'm looking at it for my
own specific unique point of view and
and I haven't seen necessarily those
stories
commercially out there yet so it's
exciting to also create for a bigger
budget
so you don't think there's commercial
stories that have some type of a meaning
maybe just a few out there I think there
are definitely commercial stories that
have that have heart and meaning and I
think even more so today since studios
are only making five or six movies a
year they have to find a way to make
sure that these audiences coming in
relate to these characters on a certain
level and and are rooting for them and
so that I mean for example I just
watched a film and I don't know if you
would call it big budget but Barb and
star go to Vista Del Mar and I thought
it was so funny so absurdly comedic but
there is a story there about female
friendships and and and I just love that
and it it is a you know bigger budget
film with with stars and and so that
that's the kind of work that I'd love to
make at some point sure was that an a24
movie that was a Lions game oh okay all
right I thought I've seen trailers for
it and I I looked cute I was like okay I
would watch it it's great I loved it
how did you learn to write screenplays I
took a semester of playwriting in
college and also a semester of
screenwriting so
in our screen writing class we had a
book called The screenwriters Bible
which taught us the the structure and
the technical aspects of screenwriting
and we
we're supposed to have a finished script
coming out of that class which I did not
I I believe my script was about 50 pages
long and and actually went back recently
to go look at that script to see if
there was something
I could Salvage out of that story and it
was just terrible it was so bad and
and and I thought that was really funny
because I'm like oh that just means you
know I've grown so much since that first
script that I never finished and and now
my scripts are like I said each script
that I write is is better than the last
one and that was that's what's exciting
is to see the progression of
writing from
class my first class to to my writing
now why was it terrible
it
is the story just was didn't really make
any sense I guess and the characters
didn't have specific point of views and
they were just in these scenarios and
scenes with no Rhyme or Reason it was
just really bad all across
everything
so they were just sort of like
situations and yeah conflict yeah yeah
and like I said I never finished it it
was about 45 to 50 pages and and I don't
even think when I looked back on it I
think I read the first two or three
pages and I was like oh I don't I don't
need to finish reading this
shitty script that I wrote back in the
day
so stage plays also you said you learned
to write why why not focus on that as
well well what is it about the screen so
something about stage plays because even
when I was
asked by Accenture where do you want to
live obviously I had a couple different
cities in mine it was Los Angeles New
York and Chicago
and I really decided that I was going to
forego the New York City theater scene
because I didn't feel like I ever saw
people of color in Broadway plays and so
it just didn't feel like the right place
for me and that I wouldn't get any work
and so but I was always seeing people of
color in commercials and stuff so that's
what made me move to Los Angeles and
that was the same kind of thinking in
terms of going into playwriting or
screenwriting I did not see
plays that were written by or for people
of color to be honest or enough of them
but I had like I said I had watched
Sethi G3 films and I had seen and I knew
Bollywood was a big thing in our culture
and so I was inspired by the films and
the TV that I watched and it felt more
attainable to me
why is it so important to write a
perfect first draft
it's not important to write a perfect
first draft I like I said I always write
a thumb at first draft and it's actually
terrible and writing is all about
rewriting so for me I'm just trying to
get to the page count and once I get to
90 I get really excited and that is
cause for celebration and then I go back
and I look at my draft and it's terrible
and so I look through it and I do my own
version of a second and third drafts of
that and then that's when I get to
send it off to my four or five friends
that I trust to give me critical smart
notes that will actually help move the
script along and then I gather those
notes and I read through them and and I
see if any of the notes are actually
similar and I tackle those notes first
and then at this point I'm at the fourth
fifth draft of the script and it's
getting there but it's not perfect and
then I I tend to finish a script when
it's on at sixth or seventh draft
that many okay
do you outline
I do outline so going back to Thomas
Lennon's book how to write Movies for
Fun and Profit he has this really great
chapter of outlining where his outlines
are like 20 pages long so if you do a
very
specific long outline where you know
exactly what the scenes are going to be
and who the characters are in each scene
you can transfer that into final draft
and then have just the scenes in there
but then you are writing the characters
and the dialogue so when you transfer it
over to final draft it's already like 15
20 pages in and so it's way easier to
write and finish a script if you have an
amazing outline and you know exactly
where it's going to go and then you can
even hop back and forth so what's
exciting to me is like I said I I don't
write and unless I'm getting Joy from
the script and so maybe I want to write
the ending first so then I write the
ending because I already know what
scenes are necessary to get to the end
so then I just write that ending and
then I work backwards
so your writing process sounds like it
it varies it's not like you start a
script the exact same way every time it
varies with each project and sometimes
I'll just get an idea and I'll start
writing and I'll be like Oh I'm writing
where's this gonna go
maybe it goes nowhere but maybe it does
go somewhere and so every project that I
write it's it's a different process in
terms of getting it down on the page
even with cowboy and Indian when I wrote
cowboy and Indian I saw it more visually
than with a lot of dialogue so I just
wrote the visions of the scenes down and
then it it was birthed out of that
so going back to the Twitter thread from
a few months ago that I saw about the
right way and the wrong way to do
something and sort of you know the film
community and their opinions on it it
sounds like
you just have different styles for each
script that you work on and it all ends
up working out it just there's no real
process that you follow every time for
each one there's no real process that I
follow and and I think that that's what
keeps it fresh in my mind and that's
what keeps me coming back to
screenwriting with my every story every
idea that I have
there's a new way to approach it and
whether it's uh Thomas Lennon's way of
approaching something which I I really
connected to or whether it's just
writing down certain uh ideas or visions
or what's a cinematography is going to
be and that's that's a whole different
way of looking at approaching a script
with engineering classes did they teach
you the same different ways to approach
problem solving
so it won't be a b and c every time for
the same problem yes so something that I
went through after as I was getting my
degree was I was interviewing for a lot
of different jobs and even though I had
the Accenture jobs I would go to these
interviews to be like oh maybe they're
gonna offer me more money who knows and
so I was in an interview for McKinsey
Consulting which is one of the big fancy
Consulting groups that a lot of Ivy
League graduates work for and
they ask the same type of questions in
these interviews which
are big ques big macro questions that
don't necessarily have a correct answer
but they want to see your brain process
of how you would get to that answer so
one of the questions that I remember
getting in this McKinsey Consulting
interview was how many French fries
does McDonald's make every year
so how would you go about answering that
question and there's different ways to
go about it there's you know you could
start with okay what does a McDonald's
sign say serving this many million
people every year you could start from
there and work backwards towards okay
how many how many french fries are in
one pack how many how many people come
through there per day and how many
cities are there in the United States
how many McDonald's are there in America
so you you go through this process and
you have to say the process out loud to
the interviewer so they can understand
your brain thinking skills and then you
get to a number at the end but it could
be a totally unrealistic number it
doesn't matter what that number is it's
about how you got there
can you tell us more about how you wrote
definition please yeah so I was in a UCB
sketch writing class in 2015 and every
week we had to write a new sketch so
always coming up with new different
ideas and one of my sketches was
entitled spelling bee winners where are
they now which was based on my fourth
grade spelling bee experience and if you
research spelling bee winners they are
all doing amazing things they are
working for NASA they are designing
robots they are winning the World Poker
Tournaments and and I just thought it
would be funny if one of these spelling
bee winners grew up to be unsuccessful a
loser living in their mom's basement
playing video games just not doing much
with her life so that was that was the
gist of my sketch and this was four
pages long and then I in at the end of
2016 I got into a Sundance screenwriting
lab and I went to the screenwriting lab
and it was really inspiring and amazing
and in 2017 a couple months later I
decided to go to the Sundance Film
Festival for the first time and I went
as a Sundance influencer Sundance asked
me to take over their Instagram and
their Twitter and go to certain events
and interview people and it was actually
a great way to experience a first
Sundance kind of within the Sundance
family and my friend Justin Chon's film
was playing there and so I went to
this premiere of and was just
completely blown away by the film and I
cornered him at his post party and I
asked him how he got it made and he said
I just got money from my friends and
family and we just went out and made it
ourselves and I was like great that's
what I'm gonna do so I went back home
after that first Sundance and started
jotting down ideas for definition please
based on that sketch that I had written
uh
two years prior
and then throughout 2017 I worked on the
first draft in 2018 I worked on
subsequent drafts of the film and a
question I started with that premise of
okay what happens when a spelling bee
winner grows up to not fulfill her
potential and I took that question and I
asked okay what what would be the
reasons why this would affect her in in
not taking a job somewhere in
um moving on with her life and and I
decided to answer those questions by oh
it's her relationships with her family
with her mom with her dad with her
brother and and her community in general
and so I Incorporated those aspects into
my script and as
I believe at the end of 2018 I had my
shooting draft of my script and I was
ready to
either get a production company on board
to shoot it or shoot it myself
and you approached family and friends
so
in terms of making the movie I had gone
back to Sundance in 2019 this time with
HBO and Justin's next film is purple was
premiering there and I got out of that
screening and I was like Justin has made
two films in the time that I told him
that I was gonna make my film I am
disappointing myself with not getting
out there and shooting my film then and
there I decided I'm gonna shoot
definition please in the summer of 2019.
and so this was January 2019. as soon as
I decided I got an email out of the blue
saying that a show that I had sold
to a studio was caught up in the merger
in the Time Warner merger so they were
now releasing the rights back to me
along with sending me a gigantic check
so I was like well this is a sign
because I had just decided to shoot my
film so I took that check and put it
into definition please and I was the
first money into my film as an investor
and then I got back from Sundance and I
just went full force in raising money
everyone I talked to everyone I had
coffee with everyone I was hanging out
with I would say hey can you put money
into my movie or do you know of anyone
who would put money into my film and so
the thing with artists and actors in La
is they don't necessarily have a ton of
money to just be willy-nilly investing
in other people's films but they do have
cousins and they do have friends who are
maybe necessarily not in the industry so
they want to dip their toes into the
industry and something that I noticed
was that since I had already put money
into my film it was easier to get other
investors on board and put money into
the film and then we just raised all the
money and we were as we were raising the
money we were prepping to shoot so we
were getting our crew together we were
getting our cast together and I did not
have auditions for the cast I just
texted my friends who I knew would be
right for the roles and a lot of them
luckily said yes and were down to come
to Greensburg to shoot my little film
with me and then we got to Greensburg
and we shot the film
where did you put everyone up did they
stay at your parents house no no we
actually got
um an extra producer came in at the last
minute and we got this influx of money
which was really great and we got to put
everyone up at a Hampton Inn nearby and
they all had a blast it was next to his
sheets I don't know if you're from
familiar with sheets in Western
Pennsylvania but sheets is an MTO sort
of attached to a gas station but they
make these incredible sandwiches
especially breakfast sandwiches that I'm
obsessed with called schmiscuits
schmuffin schmeagle's and just these
delicious Fresh Foods and the Hampton
Inn was walking distance from a sheet so
a lot of our cast and crew also got
obsessed with sheets like I am so that
was really exciting but that but what
was also really amazing amazing about
the Hampton Inn was it was only about
two or three years old so it felt like a
new hotel and they had breakfast every
morning and and I really believe in
taking care of cast and crew and it just
makes the overall atmosphere of the film
uh just better and if if the cast and
crew are happy then you'll have a good
product and everyone will be working
well together and and I truly believe in
that so I was really excited to be able
to put everyone up in in a nice-ish
hotel and give them rental cars and oh
wow and fly them out and and it was
great
it's interesting because two of your
your very important projects all came
with a found like Newfound money like a
check that showed up
that you weren't really expecting I just
find that interesting yeah and you know
what like sometimes when people get
Newfound money they spend it in
different ways they'll put a deposit on
a house they'll take a trip they'll
um decide to start a family or what have
you and and for me my priority has
always been my work and so I there is
never any question of
I'm going to put this money back into my
work obviously
I have a quote here I think from you I
decided to take it into my own hands and
write the dream rule I always wanted to
play
so I've been in Hollywood for a while
and I've auditioned for a lot of roles
and a lot of the roles that I was
auditioning for tended to be
the the same type of roles so they were
very they were stereotypes they were
putting me in a box of these characters
would be going through an arranged
marriage or they would have strict
parents or they would be
pursuing a career that they didn't
necessarily want to pursue but they were
too afraid to do the other thing and so
I just noticed you know like a couple of
those roles I'm like oh okay this feels
interesting this feels like a new way of
telling the story but then it just kept
happening that it was the same role over
and over and and I just I didn't really
understand it but then but then I
understood that Hollywood sees different
ethnic groups as monoliths and only sees
this person in this type of role as as a
doctor or or a smart Tech person and
so for me
I just wanted to be able to
play a role where where it was more
nuanced and maybe there are bits and
pieces of that as as in in definition
please Monica does have a science
background which is somewhat of a
stereotype but I wanted to take that
that that genius stereotype and that
science background and
Verge it into something new and that I
hadn't seen before and and I said okay
well you know she smokes weed and she
hooks up with guys and and she's pretty
chill except in this one family
department and so it was exciting for me
to play and create a role that had so
many facets to it instead of this one
thing and and that's what I set out to
do in terms of casting
the rules in my film a really fun story
for me was when I uh got a hold of Anna
Kaja who plays Jaya the mom in my film
and she said yeah of course send me the
script and then I sent her the script
and
she responded by saying I've played a
lot of South Asian moms she has played
uh priyanka's mom in Quantico she has
played jamila's mom on the good place
she has played ritesh who is plays a
role of sunny in my film she played his
mom on his TV show stitchers
already so she had already played his
mom before and she said I've never seen
this role before and this is really
exciting because the mom in my movie has
such a fun Arc and she said that it was
just going to be really fun to play that
role because she had never been offered
something like that before and and that
was exciting for me to hear because I
wanted to not only write the role for
myself that I wanted to play but I
wanted to write other characters that my
friends who had maybe been offered
certain types of roles in the past that
they would also be excited to come in
and be like oh I've never gotten to do
this before thank you for giving me this
opportunity
and your brother has an ark too yes yeah
all the characters I I definitely wanted
to make sure that every single character
has has their own story in their own
Journey
how do you feel about actors who refuse
to write roles for themselves create
their own work so they don't want to be
put in a box they don't want to have to
play the same type of person over and
over again but then they're not willing
to create work that they actually want
to watch
I feel that
just don't have uh like the patience or
the discipline to sit down on a computer
and write their own roles but then I say
you got to go out and make writer
friends
make these writer friends you got to
make these filmmaker friends these are
director friends and and get them
excited about your story get them
excited about the roles that you want to
play and that you haven't seen so if you
feel like you can't do it yourself then
surround yourself with other creative
people who maybe can do that for you and
in this day and age do you think it's
reasonable for people not to want to
create their own work because it's it's
not about sitting home waiting for
someone to call anymore so much of work
is self-generated today I think in this
day and age you really do have to go out
and create your own work and there's no
excuses anymore like I said the iPhone
13 just came out and if you've looked at
the Cinematic mode of that iPhone you
can make an amazing short film shot on
the iPhone 13 and get sound equipment
from Amazon and just have it have really
great cinematic quality and have really
great sound and
you don't even have to go that far there
are Tick Tock videos that I watch of
different people and their parents and
their grandparents that are just as
exciting and even if you don't feel like
you can go as far as to make a short
film you can make little videos on Tick
Tock or YouTube or Instagram live and
figure out what works for you and maybe
put videos up on Snapchat and if that
doesn't work for you then take another
path like I said it's all about taking
risks it's all about actually doing it
so even if you think oh I can't write
this for myself then
make a friend go to these UCB sketch
writing classes go to these improv
classes you'll make friends in those
classes that's what I've done and then
you continue to work with those people
that you really gel with and that's
what's exciting so find your community
and I'll create work together
do you wish you had started writing
earlier in your career I started writing
pretty young so I started writing short
stories and poems and songs since I
don't know second grade or something I
was always really into my books I was
always really into stories when I would
go to
the Indian parties with my parents on
the weekends graduations birthdays and
anniversaries and thanksgivings I was
always sitting in the corner reading my
book just into my stories and that
inspired me to write my own stories and
so I've I've
written stories that I've transferred
into scripts and
so I started writing very young and I
was always really good like I mentioned
I was really good at math and science
but all I was also good at English too
so that was part of it and I enjoyed
writing it gave me a break from the from
the rigid structure of math and science
and and it was always a stress reliever
for me so I I really enjoyed writing
from a very young age so transferring it
over to screenwriting wasn't a hard
thing to do for me
so when you would be going to those
parties and family barbecues whatever
and you had the book where people like
put the book down come join us what are
you doing never never that that's not an
Indian thing to do
okay oh she's studying reading like
babysitters club or Sweet Valley Twins
or Sweet Valley High I wouldn't
necessarily be studying but but in the
Indian American Community you don't
really stop a kid from Reading okay ever
do you feel you have a choice to write
direct and act or it's a compulsion
like you can't not do it it's a
compulsion
and I think it goes back to your first
question of having a backup plan
and
there's honestly I think there have been
various acting classes that I've been in
out here and they always say if there's
anything else that you want to be doing
you need to go out and do that instead
of being in entertainment
there's honestly nothing else I would
rather be doing and I know that if I had
stayed at that job at Accenture I would
be making billions and millions of
dollars at this point and been promoted
and
that just wasn't it for me and it it's
not about the money and it's about
waking up every day and getting to live
my dream and that's what keeps me going
and that's where the compulsion comes
from
do you ever have friends that took that
path and there's nothing wrong with that
path who say why I secretly Envy you I
love that you went out on your own
and you kind of forged your way and you
didn't
worry about whether you had this title
or that at this point
all the time
lots of friends who went a certain path
that they were
maybe supposedly had to go down because
of what their parents said or just
because of what a community says or what
society says in general what you can and
cannot do with your life what you have
to be doing at the age of 25 at the age
of 27 at the age of 30 and
uh yeah there are a lot of friends that
are envious of what I'm doing and
um
I'm just really happy to be living the
life that I'm living
how many characters have you actually
created for yourself
multiple I've created so many characters
for myself and some of those characters
have probably never made it to the
screen but they're still on the page or
they're still in my mind and
and it's exciting because none of them
are the same and they're all based on
maybe something small something real
that has happened to me an experience or
a thought or an inspiration
um
but but all those characters are so
different and that's what's exciting
because there are so many roles that
I've created for myself that I'm excited
to play very soon and to
uh imagine them visually on screen is is
what I live for
what's one that you haven't created yet
that
you want to play like it would really
take you out of your comfort zone or
challenge you
I felt like my role in definition please
was pretty challenging that's one of the
most dramatic pieces that I've ever
written it's definitely a
dramedy but but it it leans into that
drama uh for bits of the script and and
I think going to those vulnerable places
as an actor I was just really lucky to
surround myself with amazing actors that
truly brought it and and made me a
better actor and so um playing the role
of Monica in definition please was very
challenging and very fulfilling on its
own and and and I believe that there are
roles
percolating in my head that that I'm not
aware of that that will come out at some
point and I'm excited to face the
challenge of those rules too
and I know you get asked this a lot but
how much of sujata was in that role
not a lot not a lot I think uh like I
mentioned the the entire script was
based on me winning the my class
spelling bee so I obviously never won
the National Spelling Bee or else it
would be
googleable
but uh that definition please and that
character was based on a lot of
different experiences and people that
I've come across
in my life
um being around a really large
flourishing Indian American community in
Western Pennsylvania and then also
college and after college I I took
little pieces of of my life to create
the fictional world of definition please
and so instead of a coming home story
it's a leaving home story because the
character has options she just chooses
her surroundings
yes okay and I don't care maybe I'm I
don't know spoilers here but how come
not not a coming home story where you
where you decided to come home to
um the same situation
but you you had the career what was the
difference why did you why did you do
the opposite
I think what was really exciting for me
to explore with Monica is the idea of a
stunted growth the idea of
I've been successful I've had the peak
of my life what is ever going to be
better than winning the National
Spelling Bee
and those thoughts in your head oh
nothing's ever going to top that it's
like being the quarterback of the
winning team senior year of high school
and then 20 years later you are not
really doing much and so that that kind
of story is exciting to me of like a
stunted growth of
of how is this
how is my life like and how can I get
out of it as opposed to a coming home
story I feel like I've seen that many
times before and and I wanted to explore
something new in terms of uh in terms of
what you said a leaving home story so
reliving the glory of the desert because
some people high school was not their
Glory time yes and and that was actually
an awful time and they don't want to
relive it but then there's others that
they do you're right they peek at a
certain age and I do I would imagine
that would be very difficult and and and
then they don't nothing sort of the
magic never happens again yes yes
that's what's exciting to me that that
story